Don and Mona champagne are a married
couple who live in a wealthy
neighborhood in New Orleans they have
two lovely children have a successful
business running and are highly
respected in the society at first glance
it appears as if they are the perfect
family but the reality is completely
different Mona is actually a dominant
woman who wants everything done her way
she has made several rules in the house
which have to be followed by the
children and even her husband if they
disobey she makes sure they consequences
eat your broccoli or no cell phones what
no Mom you can't are you crazy Mona has
also made a goal book in which she has
planned her week's routine in advance
she calculates everything so
meticulously that there isn't even a
minutes time to spare one example is she
has set exactly 15 minutes for the
couple to have Kus at night she has also
specified the color of undergarments
they have to wear for the occasion Don
is not allowed to get intimate with her
at any other time and this has left him
feeling desperate I'm sure there are
plenty of married men in the world who
would give their left nut for 15 minutes
a night as for the kids Allison and
Andrew they must always win everything
they participate in whether it's a
school competition or a friendly match
with a neighbor they have no other
choice Mona is always lurking around and
making sure they are giving their best
rock paper scissors you don't know what
you've done as expected Don is not happy
with the situation he doesn't have any
authority over the family and can't even
influence his children we learn that he
is the manager of a furniture store
which is supposed to be a big deal
however we also learned that Mona's
wealthy parents provided the funds for
the store which means that Mona is
technically the owner this is probably
why Don agrees to whatever she says and
doesn't have his own opinion he may own
a furniture store but he's sure not
slinging any wood one day the furniture
store announces a vacancy for the
position of a salesperson person
answering it a beautiful young woman
named dusty shows up Don is instantly
Smitten by her charm and he fails to ask
her the important questions regarding
the job after she departs Don's other
employee Les suggests that he hire the
girl he reasons that they need a
beautiful face to divert their minds
from their busy schedule Don also
remembers his stressful marriage so he
hires Dusty without even considering the
other applications I'll sling some wood
yet on the other hand and we see a shady
looking man who has just killed someone
he watches a TV advertisement of DA's
furniture store and gets an idea from
the following day the man starts
following Don and his family wherever
they go don is completely unaware about
this and he continues living his
monotonous life but as the days pass he
and Dusty start getting closer to one
another they also end up having coidus
which is a huge relief for Dawn this is
the first time in years he has made made
passionate love he's back to slinging
wood for the next few weeks Don appears
to be at his happiest he is always in a
good mood whether it be at home or work
he also starts ignoring his wife as he
has found someone more interesting than
her but as they say every action has its
consequences Don has no idea what's in
store for him next one day Dusty
approaches him with the news that she is
pregnant this freaks him out and He
suggests she aborted immediately however
Dusty vehemently refuses saying she
wants to keep it this leaves our guy in
a very difficult situation if his wife
somehow finds out about this he is
doomed that evening he meets his friend
Les for advice the latter claims that
women like Dusty are only after the
money so he suggests that Don pay her a
good amount for her silence heeding the
advice Don collects $113,000 from his
savings and just gives it to her the
next day you're worth exactly this much
to me Dusty acts a bit surprised in AER
she is definitely not after money but
then she says if that's what you really
want I'll take it after she departs Don
feels like he has dodged a bullet and
breathes a sigh of relief unbeknownst to
him Dusty goes to the same Shady guy
from earlier his name is Murphy and it
turns out she is working for him the
gang goes after wealthy individuals and
extorts money from them in this instance
Murphy noticed Don's advertisement so he
researched his family for weeks after
confirming that they are wealthy he sent
his girlfriend Dusty to seduce him the
plan worked and they have now got their
money however Murphy is not satisfied as
he had expected more so he orders Dusty
to Blackmail Dawn for more money say
that you got him pregnant this time over
the course of the next few days she
torments the poor guy demanding that he
pay her 25,000 in exchange for her
silence since Dawn doesn't have that
kind of cash he finally decides to
reveal everything to his wife wife he
goes into her room Downs a few shots of
whiskey and tries to tell the truth
however he still can't put himself
together as he is scared of the
consequences but when Mona shouts at him
to speak up he eventually discloses that
he had an affair with Dusty the store
saleswoman surprisingly she doesn't
react much Mona calmly opens a family
photo album and while going through its
Pages she asks Don if he loves her he
nervously replies that he loves her and
their children a lot he also says that
he would do anything to rectify his
mistakes in the next scene we see that
Mona has gone completely Rogue she is
shouting at the top of her lungs while
throwing objects around the house as Don
sits on the couch in complete silence
she reminds him of all the sacrifices
she and her parents have made for him
just then Dusty calls Don which he
doesn't answer she is still blackmailing
him for the money when Mona sees this
she orders her husband to accept the
deal she says that anyone who messes
with her family will end up in the grave
she then gives her husband two choices
either kill Dusty and finish this drama
once and for all or she will divorce him
and take custody of their children
hearing this Don is left shell shocked
but he isn't in any position to make
demands either so he reluctantly agrees
the next morning Mona helps her husband
by preparing a potent drug which will be
used to incapacitate Dusty Don is
arranged for a meeting with her that
evening although he is still having
second thoughts about it cut to that
night Dusty meets da at his store and
the two engage in a friendly
conversation he talks to her in a weird
manner but assures her that everything
is fine he then offers her the spiked
drink which she consumes without
thinking much after a while when the
Drug's effects start showing Dusty
realizes that she has been betrayed
however before she can run away from
there she collapses to the ground after
a while Mona arrives there and orders
her husband to put the body in their
car's trunk when they reach home Don is
ordered to strike the woman with a
hammer but he is too scared to do it so
Mona takes matters into her own hands
and finishes Dusty off Dusty may have
nailed her husband but she prefers the
hammer she then takes the dead body to
the garage and dismembers it bit by bit
while doing so she doesn't show any
signs of remorse or disgust instead she
appears to be enjoying it Dawn on the
other hand BEC so overwhelmed that he
ends up puking in the next scene Murphy
and his gang grow concerned as Dusty has
been at a contact for the past few days
they suspect that dawn has something to
do with it so they leave a note for him
asking him to meet them in private they
have also attached some pictures of his
family threatening to harm them if he
doesn't comply scared Don meets them at
a bar that night he confidently says
that he gave $225,000 to Dusty when they
last met hearing this Murphy believes
that she has run away with the money and
is never coming back again so he asks
Don to compensate him with 25k more or
else he will bring harm to his family
not knowing what to do Don once again
approaches his wife and reveals
everything to her and just like before
she appears calm almost as if she has a
plan in mind that night they arrive
outside Murphy's house which appears to
be vacant at the moment da stays in his
car while Mona heads inside she then
places something in the refrigerator
which turns out to be the dismembered
body parts of Dusty just then a gang
member shows up with his girlfriend
possibly to have a romantic time but
Mona doesn't let them begin as she
brutally stabs them with a knife in his
final breaths the gang member calls
Murphy and explains what just transpired
meanwhile Mona leaves the house and uses
a disposable phone to contact the police
she alerts them that a murder has just
taken place there in the next scene
Murphy arrives home with a friend and is
shocked to see the chaos when he opens
the refrigerator he also finds his
girlfriend's body parts this is when he
realizes that he has been set up at the
same time the cops show up at outside
the house and shoot his friend dead
Murphy is also about to be killed but he
somehow manages to escape by using a
secret underground door one day a
concerned Dawn asks his wife if she had
a traumatic past he wonders how she can
be so good at killing in response Mona
breaks down in tears and emotionally
says that her parents had always treated
her nicely she then angrily claims that
if Don asks her this question again she
will kill him and mutilate him just like
she did with Dusty hearing this Don
becomes terrified from that day onwards
he starts living in constant fear and
tries his best to avoid her another day
when a neighbor's dog enters their house
Mona angrily hands it over to its owners
she claims that she will kill the dog if
it comes here again although the owners
simply laugh thinking that it's a joke
Mona is dead serious I'm a stone cold
the movie then cuts to Andrew's
birthday where several guests have
arrived for the party when Don enters
the kitchen to get something he
Witnesses the same dog's corpse and
becomes horrified outside Andrew and
another kid are engaged in a game but he
appears to be losing this obviously
doesn't sit well with Mona so she says
out loud that the other kid is on
steroids when the boy's mom who is
suffering from Crohn's disease tries to
intervene Mona makes fun of her
condition the evil woman also chastises
her own son calling him a failure she
instead hugs her daughter Allison who
appears to be her favorite child Don
Witnesses all this from afar and feels
bad for his son he fears that when
Allison grows up she will end up
becoming like her mother so he decides
to put an end to all of this while
everyone is distracted Don goes to the
garage turns off the electricity and
Short Circuit the lamp so that it will
emit a spark when turned on he then
opens the gas valves allowing the room
to fill with gas after a while he calls
his wife and asks her to get some beef
from the garage's refrigerator the
ladder obliges and as soon as she turns
on the lamp's switch an explosion takes
place ending her life in the final scene
we see that Dawn is living a happy life
with his children he has purchased a new
house and even a car with the money his
wife left behind he is now finally free
of the constraints that were put into
him but as the movie ends the gangster
Murphy follows Dawn on his motorbike two
gunshots are heard during the credits
implying that someone has been killed
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching